i think dumbledore
is loved because he has
he's the sort of person we all wish we
had as a as a sort of inspiration as a
leader you know he seems
immeasurably good uh he seems empathetic
he seems to be able to see the good in
in everybody and the potential of good
in everybody
i think he he carries his own
morals on uh on on a slight sense of
guilt and self just self uh self um
self doubt
uh
and he does it all with mischief
and a certain sort of humor which i
think makes it very attractive
[Music]
hi i'm jude law and i'm going to tell
you
how i became albus dumbledore
[Music]
it was a privilege for me to play this
character because of
the
impact
he as a character made on so many
children through the books of harry
potter
and i was fortunate enough to ride on
the coattails of two
remarkable actors who play him as an
older um wizard um richard harris and
michael gambon of course
and so being able to go back and really
mine
the younger man
and
look at the situations the trials and
tribulations that lead and get him to
the person that we all know and love in
the harry potter series
is really the bread and butter of for an
actor it's the sort of stuff you really
look forward to
in addition he's a guy who is he has a
huge amount of power in his wizarding
skills
empathy
patience but he's also got
self-doubt and demons which this
particular film really
you really see him coming to terms with
and those are all
wonderful complicated layers
um to
build into a character
being able to go back and create
dumbledore when he was um younger than
the the character in the potter
potter books and potter films
really started for me
perhaps obviously at the
costume
fittings in the costume discussions
because
we decided very early on that he at this
point in his life was not wearing the
sort of wizard robes
the cath town and the long hair and the
large hat
and was rather
more uh professorial uh studious you
could say and
there was a sort of
elegance to him that colleen atwood our
brilliant
costume designer
drew out and and yet also a comfort and
we we sort of bounced those two
um
inspirations around and to me there was
a lot of
who he was in how he dressed a sort of
um relish
and a slight kind of uh
dandiness but also a comfort in um
you know
walking around windy corridors of
hogwarts and uh teaching children in uh
in um in turrets um
and uh
i felt from the beginning that i was
really
uh freed by the director to not feel
like i had to base him on on
the portrayals by gammon or harris that
it was very much starting from scratch
he was a guy who had a long way to go to
become
the uh the wiser
version that we all that we all knew so
for me always felt
like i had carte blanche i suppose and
that the demons that i mentioned before
were very much present the guilt was
very present and so all of that had to
be um resolved
so it was important to me to
rely on the uh the sort of twinkle
the mischievous
the all-knowing quality that we all
expected but i think what was
interesting was also to really get into
the
um regrets
and the um the guilt that that that
motivated him as a younger man
learning to come to terms with that i
think is a big reason he is such a sage
in the uh in the later films
i'm sorry to disturb you thomas but i've
just received troubling news tell me
what is it it's grindelwald
her time is closed my brothers and
sisters our wall with the michaels
begins
today
so mads and i
talked a lot about the
inevitable connection between
uh gellert and albus forever meaning no
matter how
much regret or um
divergence that they've made since they
become adults
the connection they had the uh
the like-mindedness or the shared
um ambitions of of youth
somehow bonded them
and uh eternally
and we wanted to put into place that
that sense of someone who you
you know you've moved away from you know
you
a big part of you regrets
having had that friendship nonetheless
it is there forever
it it's part of what defines you
and so we were
we were lucky we were given great scenes
to layer them into but um it was
important to us that we you know we
played we played a lot of the the love
and a lot of the friendship but equal
you know because we we relied on um
the film to explain the opposing
elements
i always base the love that dumbledore
talks about
on
an idea of dumbledore as a young man
as a boy really probably feeling quite
lonely
in the books they talk about him
being a star pupil
a a wizard
with no equal
even by the time he'd gone to hogwarts
he was this
incredibly powerful and clearly very um
uh advanced
wizard and it came naturally to him you
know it was kind of i guess like being
the ultimate in a sport and not really
having anyone to play opposite because
you're just so much better than everyone
and then he meets
gellert who is his equal
and you know the connection the sort of
boundless uh
potential
when the two of them meet forges this
incredible bond
and
a really formative age
and
you know i don't think
even though their paths lead them in
different directions i don't think he
will or had ever met anyone like that
and never will again and so the
connection is
is profound and very very deeply rooted
and i think that's what he was referring
to
i trust you're enjoying your wand mr
kowalski
can i keep this
well we're very lucky on this film the
the the world of magic is
i always think film making is the world
of magic um you know there's as much
magic in
building a set that that takes us back
to 30s berlin or the streets of bhutan
or a waterfall in um the remotest parts
of china
and and layering in the special effects
of beasts and and magic wands and
um
really
for me it was always it's always about
rooting the character and an awful lot
of the other very skilled technicians
around you
help you elevate the magic or step into
the elevated world
and um they make it very real
you know scenes like being pushed
backwards down a street and then
flipping into a tram a lot of that we
were doing on wires and
that's stunt guys and special effects
building rigs and building sets that
actually do that when the tram splits in
half they had a tram that split in half
so um
it
you know i just i just went there and
responded
if you listen carefully enough
the past whispers to you you know it's
very much a home it's a safe place for
for albus and so really my uh
responsibility was to treat it as such
but um seeing the children who play the
wizards and witches the pupils of
hogwarts
so excited and energized on the day was
a was a wonderful thing to behold
[Music]
you